[Music]
this is my you're gonna love this one I
promise
no no but no no no no no trust me
I love my mother
[Music]
hey my brother
[Applause]
so let's get after it and have us
he's an idiot
okay we got hey hey you ready for
another walk and talk the walking talks
we all agree the best way more than
breathing okay get ready
someone's a little jacked
what are you doing shirtless walk and
talk shirtless walking talk we got a
shirtless walking talk
sun's out guns out boys let's [__] go
by the way by the way you will
eventually pick up on uh uh ladies does
the best let's [__] go because it's
so sarcastic oh yeah it's great let's
[__] goal
and by the way I went I went into the uh
I went into scan police Discord this
morning I said good morning everyone
except at Danny Saint I'm stopped to
[__] find Danny Saint we're fighting
now
uh look D Dominic no it's like for I
wouldn't like not gonna fight him fight
him if we kick my ass dude I'm gonna go
uh that [__] cooler you're too stupid
gavones I hate Como [__] all right guess
what guess what some more Como [__] and
by the way look I'm not saying the whole
thing okay babe I'm just saying you
don't want to work with Danny sink
because I hear he's like real he's real
stiff that's what I heard too was to go
over Alex Stein really hurt his neck
I don't know what this is I'm walking
but I'm walking here I don't know that
it's a walk and talk whatever
it's a beautiful day well Chris you're
walking you're talking
Ergo walk it's a walking talk
he's gonna do sit and shits when he's on
the toilets in the live stream from the
toilet and I sit and [__]
smell bacon because I'm a chubber no
that's that's you in the Sun
somebody who's clearly in shape and
they're like I'm so fat that's I hate it
okay or like or when a girl's super hot
and she always goes like Oh my God I'm
so ugly shut up
nice traps though nice trap troll Chris
okay
yeah hey you got to give it to him nice
traps you know I guess a little bit of
Winnie a little test you know it's it's
summer so it's still winning he's on a
cutting cycle right now
Birds I just want to do the example
people we take seriously right
which just in your mind's eye try not to
laugh imagine Tucker doing a walk and
talk with his shirt off he would never
do that right
like he got mad that Andrew Tate didn't
want to wear a tie to the interview yeah
his walking talk would be and uh and
right now I'm walking and I smell bacon
and I'm gonna have some
what they mean to you know
can be very powerful
I have two for you here we go guys ready
for waiting for Guido fortune cookies
here they come
unfortunately cannolis Fortune cannolis
here goes a fortune cannoli you ready
it's easy one is hard okay what's the
easy one the easy one is regular okay
think about all the different
meanings of the word regular
this is like talking like to your older
cousin when you smoke weed with him bro
have you thought of like the word
regular
it's like the Insight the guy's suddenly
insightful because he's high yeah I've
watched Joe Rogan
and how it also seems to have lost its
meaning
in a few contexts I mean a real huge ass
that goes and why is the Italian man
oily you ask
is that natural Guido juice or do you
put some suntan oil on what do you think
God and he saw some shitty Long Island
beach too yeah yeah we do of course long
island has the worst beaches it's like
oh it's they don't even have sand it's
just dirt bro we didn't even really go
to the beach a lot like yeah on a Long
Island and it's all one big beach but
our beaches suck
really can't call anybody regular or
anything it goes into a CVS hey you got
extra virgin tanning oil
everybody's something Akama before you
put his mom before you go outside make
sure you put suntan oil on yeah don't
put Crisco on I'm trying to dock it on
I'm trying to look good not too much I'm
not gonna look like a [__] mulanana
yeah I'm not gonna look Sicilian man
relax
identity has become so expansive
for some people this is a cause for
concern
just looking yeah Chrissy and the chat
goes oh you mean Joe breaking point is
the most balanced new show Rogan yeah
that one see if the dogs broke out yet
um why is it cause for concern well it
messes with the idea of what people see
as regular
Right male female
maybe I gotta see the comments straight
I gotta see the comments there's gotta
be people pointing at his foot okay is
he saying that males and females are the
only two things there are wow
yeah
yeah let me hear that part again so why
is it cause for concern well it messes
with the idea of what people see as
regular
Right male female
maybe gay straight
right those are like the old I'm mate
why did he say maybe Gay because I'm
sorry even I'm trying to follow what
he's saying like really he's not very
smart so he's very using very simple
words but
why did he say maybe Gay like I don't
what did that even mean I think he's uh
maybe saying the quiet part out loud
yeah it's like you know me you know gay
straight maybe maybe you're a little gay
who knows I'm not gay I'm not me though
maybe you're a little ghetto well no I'm
not gay what did Don Lemon tell you that
guy's a [__] liar maybe sometimes
you're [__] your wife and uh you know
the image of a guy Pops in your head
that's you that's not me that's not me
hey you know sometimes bisexual Mr
Capone comes out but that's fast Lanes
the new Lanes they're too many for me to
mention
and some people see that as assaultive
on them
other people
will say well
look at the multiplying of all these
deviances what we're not going to be
able to procreate soon and look at the
rate they're increasing they're
increasing well maybe it's just the
recognition that's increasing maybe you
know what it is man it's he's [__]
probably probably chill you know he's
going for his little run or whatever he
probably took it out hey you know what
they want to help sometimes with the
pain you know I'll take a little Kratom
you know no but let me tell you the pain
so he took a little Kratom and he took a
little pre-workout and he's on a walk a
nice feeling hype
but but not only that what he's trying
to say is in his Guido voice which is
hilarious because you know you know
Cuomo doesn't believe this in his heart
we know who Como is right
Yeah well yeah but that's what I was
about to get to because he's trying to
tell you in his Guido voice like you
know maybe this day because what he just
said was like oh people are worried if
there's too many you know trans or gay
people We're not gonna be able to
procreate and he goes maybe it's just a
recognition of them he's trying to just
basically go yeah you know there's more
now but I don't think that's a bad thing
it's just that we acknowledge the fact
now you know
that's all it is like yeah there's more
like not in my family it's like yeah
it's like when somebody is like still
kind of closet races just trying not to
sound racist no that's great that a
bunch of black people are moving and
it's good it's diversity it's great
while they're moving to Florida yeah you
know or gated community quietly getting
ready to [__] move to a tax shelter
exactly
you're going through something maybe
people are searching maybe they will
identify no matter what he tells you if
one of Chris's kids turns out to be gay
it'll destroy him inside and he'll never
admit it because obviously he's gotta
you know gotta play the game as it were
but it'll destroy him all right one way
and then another and maybe that does
raise concerns about how far the kid's
going all that
it's a discussion if you want to have it
Chris I would love to have any
discussion if you were to just say
something coherent I'm having a real
sometime anything coherent he's having
these ramblings and he's not saying
anything but you don't
too many just want to point fingers hey
look no look like sometimes you think
about regular and it's gay and you know
you don't
hey you know what Chris you know what
you need a producer
all you need is a all you need is an
earpiece yeah man you need an earpiece
and a teleprompter buddy because when
you're off script you are [__]
useless it's bad
next applications of that word
so I go through it
do I have enough well first of all let's
start with the basic are you enough
my answer is definitely no
even though people in my life will say
enough you're too much okay or people in
your life Jewish
enough enough Chris
that work in finance oh yeah and in CNN
you're probably right
are you enough
for you this is the scary part is people
that can't have an audience but not
really though I mean though not really
is a hundred thousand Subs this has been
up for 24 hours it has four thousand
views our video making fun of crowder
has like 10. like you know what I mean
like in our clip channel that we barely
use like no he's not he doesn't really
have an audience he it's it's just all
typical AstroTurf [__] with him none
of this yeah and he doesn't have the
network that's buying the views anymore
and the likes yeah so now he's out here
in the [__] wild like the rest of us
doesn't it not that easy is it Chris but
I'll tell you what Chris I'll make a
deal with you and then I think Russell
packed me up on this one if you if you
really buckle down
five six seven years of this and you
show up every day five days a week and
maybe even do two shows a day
someday you'll be all right yeah you're
gonna be okay
I know for a fact rumble's fine with you
being here come over here